[Music]
according to the hollywood reporter
there's bad news for the cast and crew
of doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness apparently they're not quite
satisfied with the final outcome of the
film which means that they will have to
do a lot of additional shooting the plan
is for a six week period of six days
each week though it's entirely possible
that this is still an optimistic
estimate there are various insider
sources all of which say something
different about the exact reason some
say that additional shooting is not
unusual while others claim that massive
changes are in the works and the project
could stretch into the next year we
believe that all in all the whole thing
can be regarded in a fairly laid-back
manner subsequent filming is really
nothing unusual in hollywood although it
is of course possible that the release
date may also be delayed by a few weeks
as soon as we hear more details we will
let you know of course so far dr strange
and the multiverse of madness is
scheduled for release on may 6 2022
so far 2021 seems to be a successful
year for director ridley scott with the
house of gucci and the last do well he's
releasing two major films this year
after the release of house of gucci the
next project will be kid bag a movie
about the french emperor napoleon
bonaparte this is followed in turn by a
big sequel to gladiator the classic from
2013 movie audiences with its story
about the roman general maximus and now
more than 20 years later it is time for
a sequel the conception of the
screenplay appears not to have been
quite straightforward given that the
intention is not to merely replicate the
first part now director scott seems to
be completely satisfied with the end
result the plot of gladiator 2 mainly
revolves around the nephew of commodus
who's embodied by joking phoenix in the
original time wise this story takes
place about 25 to 30 years after the
first part so the time jump is similar
to the time that has actually passed
since the release of the original movie
also fans can look forward to an
appearance of russell crowe who played
the main character maximus in the
previous part when exactly gladiator 2
will be released is not yet known at
this point
last week was the big advertised disney
plus day the celebration of the
streaming services anniversary naturally
included all kinds of news about
upcoming movies and series especially
under the disney brand there was a lot
to report among them were the live
action and animated mix chip dale rescue
rangers and the remake of cheaper by the
dozen starring zach prath and gabrielle
union which are scheduled for release in
spring 2022 meanwhile hocus pocus 2 with
badmiddler cathy najimi and sarah
jessica parker and disenchanted 2 with
amy adams and patrick damsen are
scheduled to hit disney plus in the fall
needless to say marvel fans weren't left
out either with announcements for
she-hulk agatha house of darkness
hawkeye the what-if spin-off marvel
zombies a guardians of the galaxy
holiday special x-men 97 and much more
in our opinion the really big
announcements were unfortunately missing
star wars fans in particular were left
out in the cold as nothing was revealed
besides a behind the scenes clip of
obi-wan kenobi and some extremely short
clips from the series another drawback
is that without a disney plus account
you can watch the full promo material as
you need a subscription to do so
nevertheless it was an eventful day for
disney and above all of course for
marvel fans
warner brothers will soon be celebrating
the 20th anniversary of its world famous
harry potter movie series back then
daniel radcliffe rupert grant and m
watson bewitched every viewer in harry
potter and the sorcerer's stone and so
it is really not surprising that they
will also be a major element of the
anniversary ceremony on january 1st 2022
on hbo max to be expected of various
interviews and talk shows with the trio
and many other colleagues including
ralph feins gary oldman tom felton elena
carter and of course director chris
columbus fittingly a first trailer has
been released to tease the event on
instagram emma watson already revealed
that she was looking forward to pulling
out the time turner one last time an
appearance by harry potter creator jk
rowling is probably not to be
anticipated as she has been excluded
from public dialogue for some time it
remains to be seen to what degree the
special will then be broadcast in other
parts of the world where there is no hbo
max
he worked on the script for the fifth
part until the very end but
unfortunately he passed away in july
this year the talk is about filmmaker
richard donner of course who would not
only create a lethal weapon but is also
responsible for the cult movie superman
scrooge and the goonies despite his
impressive age of 91 donor insisted on
continuing to write the script fully for
weapon 5 because he felt it was his duty
to complete the series after his passing
manny had already dismissed the idea of
a late sequel but now there's good news
for lethal weapon fans and a fan event
in london hollywood star mel gibson
announced that he had already spoken
with the goonies star corey feldman
regarding said sequel and that even
richard donna himself had encouraged him
during his lifetime to direct the form
should he pass away the decision was
therefore easy for him to make
especially since donna's script is said
to have been quite developed gibson
should also have enough lethal weapon
experience after all he played the lead
role four times between 1987 and 1998
together with denny glover the plot
itself is still top secret and we hope
that filming will begin soon under
gibson's direction
the brand new trailer for spiderman no
way home has been available on our
channel since last wednesday the video
which is slightly over two and a half
minutes long not only sends the mood for
the third and probably last mcu
spider-man movie but is also filled with
many hidden details in this video we
introduce you to the most important
easter eggs and clues about the upcoming
blockbuster and also address the
question as to why the trailer should
convince even the last critic that
andrew garfield and probably also toby
maguire will be appearing in the film
one notable aspect is the first peek at
one of the new spidey suits we see a
black and gold superhero outfit that was
obviously co-designed by doctor strange
in the dark light you cannot make out
too many details but at least you can
see one of the doctor's familiar
seagulls in another shot you can see
spider-man's main suit which is designed
similarly to the one from far from home
but featuring gold accents instead what
we are also very pleased to find is the
brief appearance of j jonah jameson in
the trailer nostalgics in particular
will be delighted to see the head of the
daily bugle who became an indispensable
figure in sam raimi's very first
spider-man movie however doc's tentacles
have received a small makeover not only
does the fresh red paint job stand out
but the tentacles are also
significantly larger could this be a
sign that dagok is using nanotechnology
just like spidey's iron suit with the
addition of the green goblin we also get
to see another villain we were
especially pleased to see the voice of
willem the foe who to all appearances
will once again impersonate the iconic
villain of the first part he's also
spotted in a short sequence wearing a
different suit from the one he wore in
the 2002 film in another epic scene we
get to see three adversaries at once
electron left sandman in the middle and
lizard on the right the first two could
already be guessed in the previous
trailer while lizard is newly included
and looks visually the same as before
hopefully different from before will be
the deep fall of peter's girlfriend
which also occurs in the amazing
spider-man and did not end well for gwen
stacy let's conclude with two hints that
point to return of andrew garfield
spider-man in an international version
of the trailer in the scene where lizard
wants to jump on an invisible person you
can see him obviously getting hit in the
face while tom holland spider-man
doesn't even touch him this looks very
much like they digitally cut out another
spiderman here in another scene where mj
falls off the scaffolding you can see
parts of his suit arm on the railing for
only a few frames this would again match
with the video of andrew garfield on the
set of the movie which has been
circulating around the web for a few
weeks what do you think were sony and
marvel being careless here or did they
leave these mistakes in to fuel their
speculation even further feel free to
tell us in the comments spider-man no
way home will be released on friday
december 17 2021
as you have already heard in our news
the second trailer for spider-man no way
home is an absolute must see on our
channel and should therefore not be
missed by any movie fan if you also want
to dive deeper into a probable second
season of squid game then don't miss out
our latest original
[Music]